good morning thank you all for coming
I'm Robert Greenwald the president of
brave new films the video you just saw
or some of you actually have copies of
is really what helps start why we are
here today why the women are here today
I'm gonna talk for a few minutes then
each one of the women will speak and
then we'll have a few minutes for
questions so brave new films for those
of you who aren't aware is a very small
nonprofit based in Los Angeles and we do
media we do tell stories through short
films and full-length documentaries and
we've been following the me2 movement
and it's very important contribution and
it's exposure of pervasive pervasive
sexual harassment by men in power and a
shout out and expression of the amazing
work that wonderful investigative
journalists have done that's been so
important on this issue and so many
issues today thank you we all owe you a
deep expression of appreciation and
gratitude not that you're working under
the easiest circumstances but the
well-researched the time the resources
that were put into the investigations
here something that I think we will all
look back on with even greater
appreciation as we saw wave after wave
of the revelations coming we've started
to wonder although we kind of knew the
answer different men in different
businesses and there was one man who
wasn't being held accountable who wasn't
being talked about who was not being
called out and that was Donald Trump
so on November 6th we got to work we
researched all of the available past
interviews with some of the women here
and many other women all of them talking
about Trump's harassment his assault and
his predatory behavior 16 women had come
forward and we created a short video
again that you just saw that told that
story and as we worked on the video
combining and intercutting the various
clips you know when you spend two
several weeks on just this subject and
seeing and hearing these people not in
person but through film and video it
really has an impact on your heart and
your soul on your emotions these truth
tellers had come forward to warn us and
to demand our attention and in that case
in this case unfortunately when they
originally did attention was not paid on
November 15th
nine days after we started we released
the short video sixteen women and Donald
Trump online and we did what we've done
in the past we financed it through
donations from our thousands of
supporters from five to fifty dollars
and we use social media as our
distribution platform no ads no fake
dues no click bait just existing
documentary footage of sixteen women
speaking about their experiences being
harassed and assaulted by the man who is
now America's new resident one day after
we put it online almost 400,000 people
had seen it three days later almost 1
million had seen it and even more
importantly many were sharing it and
making comments on it for those of you
who know and study and spend time with
social media you know that's key right
people are not going to forward
something if they don't believe it is
honest if it's truthful if there's
something that they and their friends
and relatives are gonna learn and that's
the measure we use that's most important
and we saw that happen
very quickly again without any ads or
heart official creation it just people
were taken with it
three days later almost 1 million had
seen it and it grew to date we've had
depending on the numbers who you think
is accurate who not somewhere between
five and seven million posts and cross
posts of the video and literally
hundreds of thousands of shares and
comments it was clear people were
concerned people were angry and they
wanted to either remind themselves and
others about the women or they were they
were hearing and seeing it for the first
time women who had spoken out and who
had basically been ignored or worse
ignored and attacked timing really does
matter and it really made a difference
in this case the fact that people turned
a blind eye when these women first spoke
out but now the collective consciousness
of our nation has been awakened again
thanks to some really important
investigative work of journalists and we
know better we know a lot better
predators and harasses must be held
accountable and when the person who's
been accused that this is the president
it's really vitally important that we
don't look the other way Trump should be
investigated our elected officials no
matter what their party affiliation
should act the women who Trump
mistreated the women who suffered his
harassment assault sexual misbehavior
some of them have come together to speak
out demand action others are joining us
and will be joining us in other ways
around the country and in this too and
in this me too moment of wrecking in
this to moment of reckoning Trump does
get not get a pass and the people who
won't let him get a pass are here with
us today to tell us what happened and
what they want done hello my name is
Samantha Holvey
as a little girl I would watch the Miss
USA pageant every year and dream of
being one of those beautiful successful
incredibly confident women these dreams
never included a man lining us all up to
look us over like we were pieces of meat
these dreams never included a man coming
into the backstage hair and makeup area
while I sat naked under a robe as he
walked around looking at us like we were
his property before he moved into the
dressing room and these dreams certainly
never included this same man becoming
president of the United States I have a
new dream now that this man will be held
accountable for his actions and that
future generations of women can fulfill
their dreams without worry of anyone
treating them like they are less than
because they're a woman thank you
[Music]
well good morning my name is Rachel
crooks and I think you're all probably
familiar with my story about 12 years
ago as a young receptionist in Trump
Tower I was forcibly kissed by mr. Trump
during our first introduction mr. Trump
repeatedly kissed my cheeks and
ultimately my lips in an encounter that
has since impacted my life well beyond
the initial occurrence and feelings of
self-doubt and insignificance
I had unfortunately given mr. Trump's
notoriety and the fact that he was a
partner of my employers not to mention
the owner of the building I felt there
was nothing I could do given this
hostile work environment my only
solution at the time was to simply avoid
additional encounters with him I do
realize that in the grand scheme of
things there are far worse cases of
sexual harassment misconduct and assault
but make no mistake there is no
acceptable level of such behavior that
some men think they can use their power
position or notoriety to demean and
attack women speaks to their character
not ours which believe me is a tough
lesson learned in my case I only felt
the redemption of knowing it was not my
own flaws to blame when I read the
account of Temple Taggart whose story
had so mirrored my own that I finally
felt absolved of the guilt that I had
somehow projected an image that made me
an easy target instead this was serial
misconduct and perversion on the part of
mr. Trump
unfortunately this behavior isn't rare
in our society and people of all
backgrounds can be victims the only
reason I'm here today is because this
offender is now the president of our
country I can promise you that I would
much rather have gained public interests
because of something great that I
accomplished rather than something in
this case quite negative that happened
to me I shared my story last year
because it was relevant mr. Trump
dismissed his words in the Access
Hollywood tape as locker room talk but
having been the victim of such actions I
knew better I decided to let my
encounter beauty with him be known along
with the various others yet our stories
seemed to fall on deaf ears
recently the me2 movement has gained
momentum and women have found strength
in one another and the courage to come
forward
leading many powerful men to suffer the
consequences of their actions
Trump however has escaped his path
unscathed scathed but over a dozen women
have come forward about his sexual
misconduct and we have video proof of
him promoting such behavior in an
objective setting without question a
person with this record would have
entered the graveyard of political
aspirations never to return yet here we
are with that man as president I want to
believe that as Americans we can put
aside our political inclinations and
admit that some things in fact do
transcend politics that we will hold mr.
Trump to the same standard as Harvey
Weinstein and the other men who were
held accountable for their reprehensible
behavior therefore I ask that Congress
put aside their party affiliations and
investigate mr. Trump's history of
sexual misconduct thank you
I'm Jessica Leeds and I'm the senior
member of this group my story goes way
back and it was an episode on an
airplane where I sat next to Trump and
he decided that he was bored and wanted
some entertainment I managed to get away
from him and go away and but then three
years later I ran into him again and he
remembered me so that really stuck in my
memory years later I come to I'm come to
realize that he is serious about running
for president and I start telling my
story thirty years had elapsed at least
but I told everybody I told my friends I
told my neighbors I told my book club I
told the ladies at the Y I told anybody
and everybody that I could that you want
to know what kind of person Trump is
this man who's running for president let
me tell you what kind of person this is
so obviously when the Hollywood tape
came out and then the debates happened I
got so angry that I wrote a letter to
the editor of New York Times
they responded not just with privacy no
letter they did a video and they did a
story never in a million years did I
ever think that one day I would open up
my door and pick up my newspaper and
find my picture on the front page this
story was as simple as what I just
explained it was an encounter on an
airplane and a totally inappropriate
behavior on his part so then there was a
kind of a media scum scrum as I call it
and then the election came and he won
and I was absolutely destroyed but I
figured the United States is a big
strong country we can survive this
person but during the course of the year
I kept hearing from people who would
come up to me on the street in the
subway at the library at the grocery
store at an airport one time in the
swimming pool all all people and
everybody had a story everybody had some
experience of being vulnerable and being
attacked and you know I thought I
thought things had gotten better for
women in business but apparently I was
wrong then the anniversary came of his
election there was some renewed interest
by the media as to you know what I
thought and all that and then the
Weinstein story hit and it was like an
explosion in a shingle factory it just
things were flying all over the place
and it became apparent that in some
areas the accusations of sexual
aggression were being taken seriously
and people were being held accountable
except for our president and he was not
being held accountable in fact his staff
made a big point of calling us all liars
so we're at the position now where in
some some areas of our society people
are being held accountable accountable
for unwanted behavior but we are not
holding our president accountable for
what he is and who he is
so I'd like to see this moment I think
the me2 movement is quite fascinating
and I'm hoping that it creates more
movement and that we get a change but we
shall see and we all have to hope
stories we'll take some questions now
from the media I think our first
questions go to Francis just say your
name publication Francis sellers from
the Washington Post
you talked quite a bit about the me2
movement and I'm curious about your next
steps and what specifically you hope to
achieve in coming weeks or months in
addressing the concerns you've raised so
bravely and thank you very much for
speaking up about those
I don't because I'm not I'm too old to
have any working knowledge of how the
internet works so I don't know exactly
how this me to movement is going but I'm
I'm just hoping that it it continues
forward and it grows it's like the the
women's March in January after the
election which was incredible and it was
worldwide so I I am hoping that that
this will come forward and and produce
enough pressure on Congress to address
it more than just for their own members
but to address it in the president I'm
saying if asked but it's it's not like
we're running out with banners I don't
think any of us none of us want this
attention none of us are comfortable
with it I mean if we had been
comfortable with being a star we would
have done something else with our lives
but it is this is important so when
asked we speak up thank you very much hi
there I'm ronita young from Reuters
specifically our are three of the three
of you asking for a congressional
investigation and from what committees
and if not what specifically do you want
to happen they've they've investigated
other Congress members so I think it
only stands fair that he be investigated
as well and I think also a nonpartisan
investigation is very important not you
know not just for him but for anybody
that has allegations against them this
isn't a partisan issue this is how women
are treated every day this isn't a
partisan issue
I would I would just echo what Sam said
I mean I think if they were willing to
investigate senator Franken I think it's
only fair that they do the same for
Trump
hi Tamara with Fox News summer service
was just in court she has a defamation
suit against the president does that
give you any hope what do you hope the
outcome of that is and do you see future
similar lawsuits like that do you think
that that's your path to getting justice
you know I was asked that on my
interview in CNN last year and I mean
what am I gonna sue him for being really
creepy that's not something that would
stand up in court but what I'm more
concerned about is as a culture in our
country what is acceptable behavior and
if the standard that our president is
setting it's not high enough right now
the court of public opinion I think
would be the best place in my opinion
for this to be judged like you said it's
a cultural thing and we shouldn't let
politicians get away with this in my
situation is so old that I don't even
think they're a judge would even enter
into any sort of case on it so I and I
don't have any thoughts of going to the
courts for this it this is really a
matter of we have to deal with the the
public and we have to deal with
attitudes and and changing a cultural
phenomena here so it's I don't think the
courts are the place to go hi Allison
with CNN Jessica this is for a question
for you when you had that episode with
mr. Trump on the airplane can you give
us some details as to what happened and
also what happened three years later
just give some details about those
encounters well I was a traveling sales
rep for a paper company and at that time
there were very few women traveling
business and I was on this airplane I
cannot remember whether it was Dallas or
Atlanta but coming back to New York and
the Stewart this came down the aisle and
asked me would I'd like to come up to
first
and this had happened before I'd been
invited up to first class several times
I sat next to some really interesting
people like george steinbrenner and and
Ralph Nader and various CEOs of company
it was it was not unusual so and and the
food was so much better in first class
so I went up and sat down and this
gentleman was sitting on the window it
was right against the bulkhead and he
introduced himself as Donald Trump well
I didn't work out of New York City so I
didn't have any awareness of the Trump
name or the Trump business or Donald
Trump so we had dinner we they served
the dinner and cleared the dinner and
about that time he jumped all over me
and he grabbed me and he was trying to
kiss me and everything and as I recall
he didn't say anything and I certainly
didn't say anything I didn't yell or or
ask for help I remember at one point
looking over at the guy sitting and the
across the aisle and thinking well why
doesn't he come to my aid I wondered
where in hell the stewardess was but
it's when he put his hearted to put his
hand up my skirt and and that was the
last time I wore a skirt traveling then
I managed because I'm not a small person
I managed to wrestle myself out of the
seat and stood up grabbed my purse and
went to the back of the airplane and sat
back there until the plane landed let's
the plane de plane
all the people get off before I left
because I didn't want to run into him
again fast forward three years I'm now
living in New York City and I go to work
for the Humane Society on 59th Street
and they're going to have this big fancy
fundraising gala
at sex with Avenue and they asked me to
man the table that distributed the table
distributions so I go and
it's absolutely a New York cuisine I got
to meet all the designers I got to meet
various and sundry people because the
Humane Society as a charity was very it
was very interested in inviting all the
celebrities in town and that's when I
became aware that Donald Trump was the
Donald Trump of the Trump family of New
York City and I recognized this picture
I remembered him people remember when
they're assaulted they remember when
where why and what they had on and they
remember how they got out of it they
remember everything even if it happened
when they were eight years old
so I'm handing out the shit's for the
table and up comes Donald Trump and at
that time his wife Ivana Ivana right and
Ivana was very pregnant and I hand him
the ticket and I'm thinking in the back
of my mind yeah that's the guy and he
looks at me and he says I remember you
you're the woman from the airplane only
he used another term before woman and it
cleared the room it absolutely cleared
the room and I thought oh boy but he
went on and I went home and that was the
end of the story well that was that was
1983 when in 2016 when I realized that
he was really serious about running for
president I started telling my story to
everybody I said let me tell you what
kind of a person this Donald Trump is I
told everybody that I could get to sit
down and I told my family and I told my
friends I told my neighbors I told
everybody that some people didn't
believe me which I understand completely
because it was so long ago but I wanted
to get it out
and then the debates happened and he
lied about and also the the Hollywood
bus tapes came out and I just was so
infuriated that I wrote a letter to the
editor and they called me and I thought
I'm gonna get my letter published huh
this is really super but no they sent
over a reporter they asked for the
people that I had told over the year
they called them they confirmed the
story and then they wrote it up and
that's really what happened thank you
Amy Goodman from Democracy Now I was
wondering if each of you could respond
to President Trump
endorsing the accused pedophile Roy
Moore for the US Senate and if you feel
that President Trump should resign when
I think the endorsement is disgusting
absolutely disgusting and to I don't
think he should have been elected to
begin with I think with all of the women
coming forward and so many of the women
that we've this is the first time we've
ever met and so many of women having the
same stories and you know him just being
so braggadocious about this throughout
the years and for there to be audio and
video of him saying these things you
know it's just yes I but I believe you
know other folks have resigned
I think he should I don't think he ever
will but I think I think he should but I
think it's you know the public needs to
be aware they need to know this is this
is the type of person he is I think he
is trying to back for political
expediency somebody who's going to win
he's he doesn't have any moral compass
so the accusations against Roy Borg
you know he puts them in the same
category of well I didn't do that to
those women so why should I believe
those women down in Alabama it's really
horrifying and it's confusing because
you would think that a good the good
people of Alabama could could see
through this but we've gotten so
polarized with with the politics that it
it's that they want to keep a Republican
seat even though it's a pedophile
if I had my well I I think Trump will
eventually be forced to quit resign
probably most likely because of
financial matters in the Muller
investigation I unfortunately feel that
the sexual aggression issue is kind of
low on the list of things wrong with
Trump but it's serious it's important
enough to me to bring this up and hope
that we can get some sort of change in
our culture that will improve the
situation going forward nothing shocks
me or surprises me about Trump anymore
in fact I think his endorsement of Roy
Moore makes perfect sense for him
because he was able to just deny you
know what we said and that got him
elected just fine so you know it's like
passing the torch for Roy to do the same